OF TONIGHT'S HALLOWEEN "ANGLE"
OF TONIGHT'S HALLOWEEN "ANGLE."
TODAY, HOUSE DEMOCRATS
EMBARRASSED THEMSELVES BY
PASSING A RESOLUTION TO APPROVE
AN IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY THAT THEY
HAD ALREADY BEEN CONDUCTING FOR
WEEKS BEHIND CLOSED DOORS.
NOW, FROM THE BEGINNING, THEIR
PATTERN OF LEAKING AND LYING TO
DAMAGE TRUMP IN AN ELECTION
YEAR, OF COURSE, WAS SO OBVIOUS.
IT WAS SO CHEESY, IT REMINDS ME
OF ONE OF THOSE OLD MOVIES THAT
KIND OF SCARE YOU AS A KID, BUT
THEN MADE YOU LAUGH AS AN ADULT.
>> THESE CREATURES ARE VERY
HAUNTING.
♪ ♪
>> WHY DID YOU PUSH CAMILLA?
>> STOP SAYING THAT!
>> SHE DOESN'T LIKE PEOPLE
COMING IN HERE.
>> OH, MY GOD.
OUR HOUSE.
>> Laura: OUR HOUSE IS WHAT
NANCY THINKS.
THE WAY PELOSI AND SCHIFF ACT IS
JUST KIND OF AS GOOFY AS THAT,
IT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
SUDDENLY, THEY CARE ABOUT
HONORING THE INTENT OF THE
FRAMERS.
SPEAK OF FOUNDERS PROVIDED THE
REMEDY.
>> THE FOUNDERS GAVE THE POWER,
IF NEED BE.
SPEAK WITH THE FOUNDERS DIDN'T
WANT A DICTATOR, THEY DIDN'T
WANT A MONARCH.
>> WHAT DO WE HAVE COME A
MONARCHY OR A REPUBLIC?
THAT'S A CONSTITUTION.
>> Laura: I HALF EXPECTED
NANCY TO SHOW UP IN A
REVOLUTIONARY WAISTCOAT, BUT
THANKFULLY, REPUBLICANS ARE
CALLING THIS OUT FOR THE HORROR
SHOW IT IS.
>> THIS IMPEACHMENT IS NOT ONLY
AN ATTEMPT TO UNDO THE LAST
ELECTION, IT'S AN ATTEMPT TO
INFLUENCE THE NEXT ONE, AS WELL.
THIS IS NOT WHAT DEMOCRATS
PROMISED WHEN THEY ENTERED THE
MAJORITY 11 MONTHS AGO.
I GUESS IT'S ONLY FITTING YOU
TAKE THIS BOAT ON HALLOWEEN.
>> Laura: AND ON HALLOWEEN,
PEOPLE ARE LOOKING FOR TREATS,
AND DEMOCRATS ONLY OFFERED LAME
TRICKS.
LIKE THE ABSURD NOTION THAT THEY
ARE APPROACHING THIS SOLEMN
MOMENT WITH OPEN MINDS.
>> ONLY THE FACTS AND HOW WE
RESPOND TO THEM WILL DICTATE THE
OUTCOME.
>> I MAKE NO PREJUDGMENT AS TO
WHETHER THAT REMEDY WILL BE
WARRANTED.
>> Laura: THEN THEY TRIED TO
DISGUISE THEIR VENAL MOTIVE BY
WRAPPING THEMSELVES --
MUMMIFYING THEMSELVES IN THE
CONSTITUTION.
>> IT IS THE DUTY OF THIS HOUSE
TO VINDICATE THE CONSTITUTION,
TO HONOR THE OATH TO DEFEND THE
CONSTITUTION THAT EACH OF US
TOOK, WE MUST MOVE FORWARD WITH
THIS IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY.
>> Laura: WELL, WE SEE THROUGH
ALL OF THIS.
DRESSING IT ALL UP AS UNCLE SAM
DIDN'T MAKE THEM ANY MORE
CREDIBLE.
>> IT ISN'T ABOUT PARTISANSHIP,
IT'S ABOUT PATRIOTISM.
>> WE ARE HERE TODAY BECAUSE
GRAVE, DEDICATED PATRIOTS ARE
STANDING UP FOR THEIR COUNTRY.
>> Laura: DEDICATED PUBLIC
SERVANTS WOULD BE DOING THE
PEOPLE'S WORK OF PASSING AN
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL, THE USMCA,
AND LOWERING THE COST OF
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS.
BUT NONE OF THAT IS HAPPENING.
THEY ARE DEDICATED ALL RIGHT,
THEY ARE DEDICATED TO THE ART OF
REALLY BAD ACTING.
>> I TAKE NO JOY IN
CONTEMPLATING THE IMPEACHMENT OF
A PRESIDENT.
>> IT'S NOT A DECISION THAT ANY
OF US MAKE SLIGHTLY.
>> TODAY WAS A SOLEMN DAY, ONE
THAT NONE OF US REALLY LOOKED
FORWARD TO.
>> Laura: THIS ENTIRE THING IS
A "SATURDAY NIGHT LIVE" SKIT,
OKAY?
THEY HAVE BEEN DYING TO HAVE
THIS DAY HAPPEN.
THEY'VE BEEN LOOKING FORWARD TO
THIS SINCE THE MOMENT TRUMP PUT
HIS HAND ON THE BIBLE.
YET A DEMOCRAT DIRTY TRICK THAT
STARTED THIS WHOLE THING, THE
SO-CALLED WHISTLE-BLOWER, THE
GUY WHO TOOK HIS CASE TO SCHIFF
STAFF FIRST IS WHAT REALLY BLOWS
THE LID OFF THIS ENTIRE SAGA.
ACCORDING TO REAL CLEAR
INVESTIGATION, HE WORKED FOR
BIDEN -- YES, HE WORKED FOR
BIDEN -- ON UKRAINE POLICY WHEN
BIDEN WAS VP.
HE WORKED FOR DEEP STATE
HENCHMAN, BRENDAN, TOO APPEARED
ON THE WHISTLE-BLOWER ALSO
REPORTEDLY WORKED FOR
SUSAN RICE -- NO CONFLICT OF
INTEREST HERE AT ALL.
MORE ON THIS LATER ON IN THE
SHOW.
NONE OF THESE DEMOCRATS, THOUGH,
IN THE END, THE FIRST MOVIE CLIP
MADE CLEAR, SHOULD BE TAKEN
SERIOUSLY.
THEY ARE PARTISANS, THEY HAVE NO
PHILOSOPHY OR AGENDA THAT WILL
ACTUALLY END UP MAKING OUR LIVES
BETTER.
THEIR POLICIES, TO THE EXTENT
THAT THERE ARE ANY, SPOT ONLY
ECONOMIC MISERY AND LESS FREEDOM
FOR YOU AND FOR ME.
IT'S AN UNDERSTATEMENT TO SAY
THAT THIS IS A WITCH HUNT.
BUT REMEMBER, WITCHES HAVE THEIR
DAY, BUT WE ALL KNOW WHAT
HAPPENS TO THEM IN THE LAST REA
REAL.